this grapist that I went to school with was at this bar that I went to yesterday
I was there for a birthday party
no one knew who he was
I was there with two other people who knew him from college
and obviously I did not want to party with this person
but absolutely no one would do anything about it
so I had to handle it myself
I went up to the bartenders and I was like
hey there's a grapist here
can you get rid of him
they're like oh sorry
can't do anything about it
like yeah
I was like but he's
he's a grapist
like he's a grapist in the bar
like the
the bar that I would go to
the bar that I'm a regular at would never let him be there
but I guess that's not the rule at every bar
I talked to this other bartender that was there
he's like I can't do anything
I'm just trying to do my job
sorry okay
my bad I talked to like
a bunch of guys around me
they're like it's your word against him
can't do anything about it
finally I was like
okay let me take it on into my own hand
he was flirting with this girl
I was like by the way
you're talking to a rapist
I look at him
he looks at me
he says nothing
I walk away they don't budge
they don't move
I go back he's with his friends
I'm like by the way
do you know your friends
a grapist the friend laughs awesome
finally I said to his face
I was like why are you here leave
after that
he finally left
the fact that no one
no one in that bar was gonna do anything about it makes me insane